lebanon's crippling financial crisis is
having a disastrous effect on the
country's hospitals with the current
drastic fuel shortage the exodus of
medical workers and the lack of
equipment and medicine hospitals in
lebanon are fearing an imminent collapse
dw's rebecca ritters went inside
beirut's largest public hospital to
witness the grim reality its staff and
patients are facing
on this covert ward the youngest patient
is just two months old the nurse gives
him medication through a nebuliser to
help him breathe
nervous mum watches on
for the many patients here this
overflowing ward is their only hope
this man surrounded by a dozen others
all fighting for their lives
this is one of two corona awards in the
hospital this used to be the er room now
it hosts only corona patients the more
critical ones go upstairs to the icu
it's all already at full capacity and
the numbers continue to rise
as i'm shown into the icu it's clear a
covert patient has just died
[Music]
yet it's not only the disease the staff
here are fighting to keep these patients
alive
the machines that help them breathe
could cut out at any moment
the ventilators are powered by these
generators because the hospital can't
rely on intermittent power from the
state-run grid they have only three days
of fuel left
the fuel is at
the challenge
it challenges every day
for our children every day
it affects the patients
the
medical equipment
the chiller the cooling
so the fuel the
the most important thing in the country
is the fuel
the problems don't stop there the
hospital's general manager tells me
morale is at rock bottom
we are seeing a lot of doctors and
nurses leaving yesterday alone we had
five resignations in our nursing
department
and a senior physician also was
responsible for the
radiotherapy
program for our cancer patients
informed me that they are leaving the
hospital
so you know these are not
easy to replace
over in the hospital's pharmacy the
shelves are nearly empty the government
can no longer afford to subsidise
imports of medicine and supplies are
running out
we're hanging on by a thread i think
that you know it's probably a matter of
time before an accident happens and then
that can result in in loss of lives
as lebanon's economy collapses fear ass
abiad fears without drastic intervention
the care system will soon collapse along
with it
let's get some more perspective on this
story now we can speak to dw's basil
aridi in beirut
basil can you explain to us why this
hospital does not have access to power
from the grid
first of all you have to know that
lebanon facing too many crisis first of
all the international community when
asked for reforms on the top of the list
was the electricity sector the
electricity sector in lebanon cost the
national budget around 50 percent of the
national debt we are talking about more
than 47 billion dollars in 25 years so
it's one of the most ailing and most
corrupted sectors in lebanon so due to
that we're facing this power cut
continuously it's about 20 hours
daily uh this power cut uh the most
suffering uh sectors from that of course
the uh the the hospitals that's why we
heard yesterday the call from the head
of dr syndicate with the dw office in
berut received this letter per copy of
that letter he's asking all the the
authorities on the gas station to uh to
have to make some uh gas stations as
private for the doctors in order to
reach the hospitals and do their job uh
since the in addition to what uh the
europe mentioned by our colleague
rebecca we have to also know that the
doctors are facing another critical
issue which is that they can't fool
their cars tanks with the
gasoline
we heard as well that fuel essentially
is now the key to generate power in
lebanon i mean why is the fuel price
also rising so much
i'm now at one of the gas station as you
can see behind me some of these these
cars were parked in here since four days
and as you can see behind me some the
owner of that gas station and some other
guys from the local municipality are
asking the owner of these cars to come
to take it uh take it out from the gas
station since they can't afford gasoline
so when we are talking about all these
issues we can say that one of the major
problems that instead of the agency
sector the monopolism in the previous
days the lebanese armed forces and other
security forces they seized millions of
gallons they were monopolized by some
cartels according to one of the mp's
head of the blocks mp blocks in the
parliament he said uh in a speech from
inside the parliament that lebanon is
facing is or leaded by the cartels
cartel of the gasoline the subsidy the
goods and other medical issues and he
said he finished his speech by saying
that miami one day the ibanez will wake
up to see that the air that they are
breathing is monopolized by one of the
cartels as well
really is an astonishing crisis we're
talking about bustle what are
authorities doing
absolutely nothing i can say that it's
nothing they are just making some
israeli meetings and asking for the
international community to help but the
international community in order to help
he has certain conditions first of all
to form a government that is able to do
reform as i said one of the main reforms
in the electricity sector and to
negotiate with the imf in order to help
the lebanese people but instead we can
see that until this moment after 10
months of the resignation of the current
uh take care taking uh government until
now the lebanese authorities and the
japanese politicians they didn't have an
act to form a new government they are
struggling from here and they are asking
for this ministry or for that for that
party or that party as if they are
living in state of denial as the
lebanese local press mentioned and
describe the current situation the
japanese politician in state of denial
dw's basilarity reporting for us there
in beirut thank you